[Music]
[Applause]
look at that look who's got their Claret
jug there I love that uh full intro here
he won the Open Championship he's Brian
Harman PGA Tour uh Open championship
winner and uh now number six in the Fed
Up FedEx Cup Standing nobody cares about
that we just care about you got Hardware
there uh how many beers have been in the
cleric jug since you won I tell you what
probably definitely won too many the
first night and uh I have to say I got
it I got it up here I'm in Upstate New
York now and I gotta look inside of that
thing and boy does it need a scrub does
not make me feel great about all those
beers we were drinking out of when did
you realize that you could win the Open
Championship
I tried my best not to think about it
um but I started getting some really
good feelings like you know obviously
back nine got a big lead but I just knew
that if I could just stick to what I was
doing the the
I didn't feel like there's anybody that
could beat me I was playing really
really good I'd been putting so good all
week I just felt like I was in control
and felt like I was finally able to like
play against myself and not worry about
what anybody else was doing when did you
realize that this could slip away from
you if you did entertain those thoughts
oh yeah I mean the I mean you're I was a
ball of nerves Saturday and Sunday and I
hit some loose golf shots especially to
start the day both Saturday and Sunday
and I hit it hit it right in the middle
of a gorse bush On a reachable par five
number five um Sunday
hey Rory's making birdies John Rahman
just made a birdie and obviously you
know those guys are going to play great
you know that they're going to give you
um and they've done it and I hadn't so
it would have been a nice spot for me to
let the wheels come off but I was
probably the way I hung in there
but what's it like when you know the
gallery wants to see somebody else win
they don't care for an underdog over
there
all these little Cinderella Underdog
stories right yeah it was it was brutal
man they were uh I've always appreciated
the fans there because they're very
knowledgeable they they know when to
clap they know
you know that they they know the game
and they know guys like me they know me
by you know I can go to tour events in
the United States and a lot of people
have no idea who I am and that and
that's totally fine but over there they
they cover golf a little differently and
and uh so I've always appreciated their
knowledge of the game but boy did they
not want me to win that gun I'm watching
the press conference after you won and
you could tell the writers were looking
for any kind of angle here and it felt
like they wanted to talk to you about
hunting more than they did oh I can't
stand it over there they can't stand it
and uh that's I mean Everyone's entitled
their opinion I just
if someone's that mad at me knowing
where my Mead comes from while they
still eat me I just I just I got no time
for that
how will life change
hopefully not at all I've
so you know I wanted to change like you
don't want to be oh man I'm a grown-up
I'm 36. you got three kids I was
painting diapers and so I was up at six
three months back a bottle I mean I mean
how much can life change if I was 25 and
something like this happens you know the
temptation to be there but I love my
life I've got I got things I love to do
I got a family that's incredible so I
no it's not going to change just won't
explain how your style of game worked
when it didn't work for anybody else
I was able to drive it
um
I I drove the ball really well
um I was able to take on you know over
there the bunkers are scary but if
you're willing to take on a few of them
here and there you can get some really
good looks into the greens and
it worked out I drove the ball really
well and I was really smart coming into
the greens and I made a lot of putts I
mean that's been kind of my MO is when
when the putter gets hot I can you know
I can do really good and I just hadn't
had a week like that in a long time
where the putter was just good for four
days did you ever feel inferior when
somebody you know Rory hits at 3 40 and
you may hit it to 80 or 290. I know you
have to play your game but there's still
part of you like damn how does he he's
50 yards or 60 yards ahead of me
yeah I mean there's there's definitely
some freaks out there now I mean guys
that can just are just Uber talented but
I've been always been really comfortable
with just
you know I will say I play with Rory
um this had to be seven or eight years
ago we're playing together Memorial and
obviously what he does off the tee I
mean he's maybe the most gifted driver
of the golf ball that's ever lived I
mean I've said that you know from the
first time I played with him but he hit
this feathery little wedge shot when we
were playing together and I was like
damn I can't let him be better at me
than that at that you know like oh I had
a headshot I had the skills to do that
and so that kind of helped me be like
why well
he's not just beating me right now
because he's sitting it further he's
able to hit these little touch shots
that that I'm not as good at so I double
down on that and my short game's always
been good so I'm I'm comfortable with
how far I hit it I trained to hit it a
little bit further but I'm not gonna try
and hurt myself doing it he's Brian
Harman he's the Open Championship winner
the waggle your golf swing waggle got a
lot of publicity there over the weekend
yeah when I first got on tour I was one
of the fastest guys on tour when I was a
junior golfer you know was running
around everywhere and I just found
myself
waiting and waiting and just watching
other guys play golf and just I got sick
of always
kind of carrying the burden of being a
really fast player and that's what it
feels like when you're a fast player so
I made a conscious choice to slow down
now I've slowed down too much I don't I
don't like I don't like it yeah I want
to be able to
I want to be able to pull the trigger a
little bit quicker so I've been working
on that but at the same time it's like
I've been playing pretty good it's like
ah you know I don't hit the shots I'm
ready you know how many how many shots
did I hit when I wasn't ready when I
used to play really fast so the answer
is and I mean I know it's not it's not
fun to watch I've watched it I've
watched it on film and I don't like it
but
um see I'm conscious of it for sure but
I'm not gonna hit a shot until I'm ready
Jack Nicklaus threw the ball forever so
uh I still have your golf ball that you
sent to me when you had two holes in one
and around and then you had a whole one
on uh the 14th and you you sent it in
there so we we still have it in the man
cave
this is your man cave was looking
looking like it's getting a little
cluttered oh it's very is there anything
Ryan is there anything from the Open
Championship you would like to donate
what do you want man no clubs you're not
getting that butter I know that no
um how about how about a a signed glove
maybe for the man cave how's that
perfect
but I want to make sure now you probably
had 15 of them that you used on Sunday I
don't know if you saw I don't know what
is that ornaments I was more prepared
than it I can't get so mad at me so you
got this damn gloves for me that that is
when I have all these gloves that it
that Mike Tirico said it looked like a
pro shop underneath your umbrella with
all of the gear that that you had uh who
did you hear from that might surprise us
after you won
you know I
I've heard from so
after after getting
um heckled so much on Saturday and
Sunday it was just not surprising but it
was just really nice to hear from just
everyone back home and I didn't even I
didn't even really the thought never
entered my mind but I saw a video from
my home golf course in Savannah where
they were you know watching and I was
like man I didn't even I didn't even
think that they would be doing that it
just didn't occur to me so
uh no no one in particular it was just
nice to hear from everybody and see that
that I had plenty of support back home
did you cry
I have I have uh Kisner called me and I
got I got a little choked up when he
called me just because I know what it
meant for him to call me
um and then uh when I saw my family in
the airport yesterday got a little
choked up
um it's been overwhelming for sure but
I'm ready for it just Left Foot Right
Foot man on the next one I thought we
might lose you in one of those bunkers
it's there he could lose a lot of people
behind an army it's scary
is it fair
I don't know
I don't know if golf needs to be fair
um
the bunkers
the bunkers aren't in a place where
you're Amy like they they capture Aaron
shots so if you hit good shots you
shouldn't be in the Box we just get
conditioned over because our bunkers are
so good over here you get conditional
like on a par five and two like I'll
just blow it in that bunker and I'll
I'll be able to get it up you know up
around the hole somewhere over there you
can't do that you have to be really
smart a lot of times you'll be playing a
practice around there like why the hell
they put this bunker right here like the
bunker will be it's like it's only 180
yards off the tee and then the next day
the wind flips you're like oh
I see let's see what I was looking here
of course uh great to talk to you again
congratulations it was fun to watch and
uh hope uh hope you have a great weekend
with the family
I appreciate that thanks for having me
all right that's uh Brian Harman he is
the Open Championship that'd be nice get
a little uh gear from the Open
Championship go along with his golf ball
that he sent us multiple gloves in a
round is that commonplace for golfers
well as hard as it was raining oh yeah
yes they just dump them yeah